Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David P. Here is a really
good question about the rights and the pandemic.
Beautifully asked. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Yeah, hey, David, this is Troy
calling from Georgia. Yeah, I just had a
question for you that I don't think I've ever seen
anybody ask. You know, people that are against
vaccine and mask mandates. Yeah, I've always
wanted somebody to ask the opposing side. What
is it that you want our government to do, right.
To fight this pandemic? Nothing, because I haven't
heard any other suggestions of what we
could do other than mask up and try to
get everybody vaccinated. Yep. Do they want
to just let. This thing run rampant. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Here's this is a great question, right?
So you're against the government saying what
should happen in schools, let schools and parents
figure it out. You're against government saying
you got to wear masks. You're against government
saying you've got to get vaccinated to work here,
to work there, to go here, there to travel in
this particular way. You're against businesses
having capacity limits. They want to leave it to
the business to decide to leave it to the people
to say, oh, I want to go to this business or I
don't. Everybody will just kind of make their own
decisions. This is the point that they don't want
anything to be done. Many of them never believed
it was serious enough to have anything done
involving the government. Many of them believe
that anything government does is overreach, and
yet now they're OK with government passing a ban
on mask mandates. And so it's completely
hypocritical. But you have to understand,
they're framing is it should be freedom, leave
it to people and businesses to figure out. Except
once a business says, well, you've got to wear a
mask to come in or you've got to be vaccinated to
come, and then they want to pass laws that say,
no, no, no, you can't do that. Ban mask mandates,
ban vaccine requirements to do business. So it's
the wrong approach. This is sort of like. When
we say aren't Republicans going to be punished
for obstructing everything Democrats want to do,
no, no, no, the obstruction is a feature. If
your world view is I don't want government
doing anything or I want government doing
as little as possible, you see obstruction
by government officials as a feature rather than a
bug. They are doing the thing you want them to do.
They are preventing government from doing stuff.
And so, of course, that makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever. Extraordinarily dangerous. And
we see how it's worked out for the United
States. And particularly when you look at
the red states now or the red counties now,
case rates are growing at twice the rate in
red counties, as in blue counties. It has
failed completely. It's a perfect question,
if not masked, if not vaccines, if not,
how do they think government should be involved
in fighting this pandemic? Many of them believe
government should not be involved. And that's
a horrifying thing. And most of them would
concede even small government conservatives would
tend to concede government should keep us safe
from threats. The threat doesn't have to
be a military threat from another country,
doesn't have to be a cyber threat from another
country or bad actors. It can be a medical threat,
a public health threat. And that's exactly what
it is. So it's you have to really get into their
mindset to understand they want the government
doing nothing. They don't think the government
should be involved. We have a great bonus show for
you today. We're going to talk about what's in the
infrastructure bill, what's actually in the
bill that is going to be debated in the Senate.
We will talk about how a million Texans have
registered to vote online since a court ruling
said you can register to vote online. We
will also talk about new McDonald's policy.
Every employee must wear a mask. Every customer
must wear a mask. There are McDonald's addicts
who also hate masks who are going crazy.
What will they do? Will they go to Burger
King? Will they go to Wendy's? Will they
maybe make a salad? We will talk about
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Get instant access by signing
up right now. I mean, it's truly instant.
The speed of light at join Pakman Dotcom.